ce coup pas mal non là c'est rien
sinon on peut y retourner
moi je me disais
toutes les familles sont un peu bizarres
ça dort mais franchement y'a pas plus
bizarre que la mienne mon père c'est big
foot
alors c'est quoi la prochaine étape à
une ligne de vêtements manquent de
basket une descente aux jeux vidéo
ouais le fameux big foot on dirai pas
quand on voit comme ça mais moi aussi je
suis un bigfoot la nature passe avant
tout le pétrole vers par x tract du
pétrole vert à c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi avec notre notoriété vous pourriez
les stops et x tracts avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
[Musique]
mais à peine revenu et tu veux déjà
repartir dis moi à quoi ça sert d'être
célèbre si j'essaie pas de rendre le
monde meilleur
en europe
s'ils ont vraiment rien à cacher
pourquoi ils défendent l'entrée de leurs
sites avec des gardes de la disparition
de foot il faut qu'on l'aide
petit ça y est ça recommence
ce qu'ils appellent du pétrole vers sans
impact pour l'environnement
mama
c'est là que le héron chercher sur ce
plan dit les ballons
[Musique]
mais non tu prends
on va finir ce que tu as commencé tous
les trois
on fait des pancakes
vas-y en beauté un peu trop vous corps
trappe oses tu peux rien moi si tu es un
peu lente
ouais